i've restated stoke's theorem and what i
want to do in this video is make sure
that we get our orientation right
because when we think about a normal
vector when we think about a normal
vector to a surface there are actually
two normal vectors they're based on the
way i've drawn it right over here there
could be the one that might pop outward
like this or there might be the one that
pops inward just like that both of those
would be normal to the surface right
there and also when we think about a
path that goes around the boundary of a
surface there's two ways to think about
that path we could be going based on how
i've oriented it right now we could go
in a
counterclockwise orientation or
direction or we could go in a clockwise
orientation or direction so in order to
make sure we're using stoke's theorem
correctly we we need to make sure we
understand which convention it is using
and the way we think about it is
whatever the normal direction we pick
and so let's say we pick this normal
direction right over here the one i am
drawing in yellow so if we pick this as
our normal vector so we're essentially
saying maybe that's the top one way of
viewing is that's the top of our surface
then the positive orientation that we
need to traverse the path in is the one
that if your head was pointed in the
direction of the normal vector and you
were to walk along that path the inside
or the surface of its of the surface
itself would be to your left and so if
my head is pointed in the direction of
the normal vector so this is me right
over here my head is pointed in the
direction of the normal vector i'm
wearing a big arrow hat right over there
and if i'm walking around the boundary
the actual surface needs to be to my
left so i need to be
i need to this is me walking right over
here i need to be walking in the
counterclockwise direction just like
that then that's the convention that we
use when we're thinking about stoke's
theorem
if we oriented this thing differently or
if we said that no no no no this is not
the normal vector this is not the
the essentially the the top that we want
to pick if we wanted to pick it the
other way if we wanted to go in that
direction if we wanted that to be our
normal vector vector in order to be
consistent we would have to now do the
opposite i would now have to have my
head going in that direction
my head would now have to go in that
direction and then i would have to walk
once again and this might be a little
bit harder to visualize i would have to
be walk in the direction that the
surface is to my left and now in this
situation instead of the surface looking
like a hill to me the surface would look
like some type of a bowl or or some type
of a of a valley or something like that
to me and the way that i would have to
do it now and it's a little bit harder
to visualize the upside down cell but
the upside down cell would have to walk
in this direction
in this direction in order in order for
the bowl or the dip to be to my left so
that's just it's just important to keep
this in mind in order for this to be
consistent with this right over here put
your head in the direction of the normal
vector or you can kind of view that as
the top of the direction that the top of
the surface is is is is going in
and then the the contour that you or the
direction that you would have to
traverse the boundary in order for this
to be true is the direction with which
the surface is to your left